good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 1124 object
class Keter special containment
procedures all samples delivered are in
containment the distance of from Earth
and the conditions on the planet itself
render any breach of containment of
active instances of a sepia leaven 24
unlikely these entities have been
observed to be exclusively terrestrial
they repeat of the lander incident at
Air Force Base is unlikely as no more
than one Lander and shuttle was
stationed at eleena at the time of the
outbreak research drones have revealed
that the since missing shuttle is
currently eroding on the planet's
surface samples of SCP 1124 have been
transferred to warehouse compound 11 24
X 8 as per recommendation by doctor
researcher Sanders dr. Herman and dr.
Smith have been given special clearance
to access the samples at their own
discretion with the conditions that
update logs and proof of an activity or
reactivation are immediately placed on
record indefinite surveillance of the
researchers is enacted as a precaution
with the exception to the Alina incident
no instances of scp-2483 the housing
compound is located 70 kilometers
underground outside of site and is
equipped with a fail-safe nuclear device
showed emergency protocol fail
individual instances of scp-2401 meter
cubed steel blast safes isolated
instances of sep11 24 are kept
individually in steel stores with
equipped motion and heat sensing
equipment no more than one instance of
tested at any given time testing is to
be done with approval from each of the
three affer mentioned personnel site
director and o5 directorate approval
it is recommended drones instead be sent
to alina for research should defensive
systems within the testing chambers fail
the chamber is to be immediately sealed
filled with try flick acid and
incinerated any researchers present
inside of the testing chamber are to
remain there during the termination
protocol efforts are being taken to
destroy SCP 1124 see before it matures
although with current results this seems
unlikely the progeny itself is contained
in a three meter cubed containment unit
with acid proof titanium sheeting the
container should be completely submerged
and recycled with true flick acid at all
times the unit itself is to be lined
monthly with extra titanium sheeting to
replace dissolved or destroyed sheeting
this maintenance process should be
completed within a span of 40 minutes
description sep11 24-hour metallic
objects found near research base iliena
on the first instances of scp-2401 tonry
entities contained by the canisters have
the appearance of cephalopods weighing
exactly one point zero two six eight
kilograms instances of scp-2401 to
external stimuli safe for physical
contact with biological matter which
will cause instances of a sepia leaven
24 to activate and reaction to
biological matter originating from a
sapien creature tends to elicit a more
violent response
though observations are performed daily
through a viewing window in tank 1124
see by monitoring cameras a definite
shape can not be substantiated the most
recent appearance appears similar to a
larval grub as CP 1124 C is in all
instances metallic in appearance the
entity frequently nas and consumes the
casing in its containment unit although
the amount of damage taken is acceptable
due to the density and thinness of the
film used to line the chamber further
research into containment is deemed
necessary as the creature has been shown
to grow in minor increments when more
material is consumed a tear
located in researchers bodysuit during
transfer allowed activating one instance
of scp-2401 the inside of its alloy
casing and then launching itself into
the mouth of one researcher this method
of mobility is believed to be a
spring-like motion using its appendages
but this is still unconcerned following
containment procedures researcher sealed
himself inside unit 1124 C and activated
the failsafe mechanism effectively
containing a CP 1124 C C incident report
1124
termination dossier this is X 23 C Alena
6555 - X 23 Lander transmitted data
playing log now 1331 dr. Sanders audio
log 8 20 reporting successful mission
samples are being housed we think our
glass canisters were found beneath that
mountain range 84 South to 3 East on
your grits estimated 4 minutes before we
reach the rover
13:34 reached over ahead of schedule
everyone is present and accounted for
estimated one hour before we reach Alina
1425 we're in the airlock now we've
dumped our Carville researcher Breen
reports he is delivering the recovered
canisters to DOMA theta 1440 signing off
335 met with Bremen he hasn't said
anything about the canisters yet saving
the best for last he says don't know how
he can resist something that bizarre yes
that's why we got him up here 6:58
meeting with Breen again let me turn up
my transmitter here say something bring
greetings from space you're a silly
[ __ ] Breen oh seven five he's got a few
of the things that were inside the
canisters laid out on the table Breen
says the canister itself wasn't glass
though not sure what the material was
the canisters are egg-shaped no markings
smooth
they have lids on their ends that detach
and reattach give it a gentle pull there
are no adhesives no screw tops or
anything like that they just come off
and on oh seven ten the things inside
the eggs look like little silver squids
their limbs are segmented can't make out
any eyes or mouth green strip one around
but the limbs didn't wiggle like we
expected them to they're stiff Oh 712
Breen can't begin dissection their outer
shells are too hard thinking they might
just be figurines or something like that
I was 726 Green has blasted these things
with heat throws him even put them in a
crusher and they don't seem to react at
all they just sneeze off anything we
throw at him
Oh 727 he joked that we should sneeze on
them
Green gave me the honors Oh 728 couldn't
sneeze so I just spat on one they don't
seem to be affected think they might
just be figurines Oh 728 mother mercy
one of these appendages is actually
moving reference addendum 1124 audio a
for the one-hour transmission playing
log now
[Applause]
SCP 1124 addendum a alina lander
returned to Air Force Base in Nevada on
20 without a shuttle 65 55 - X 23 was
obtained by the organization after being
alerted to the circumstances of its
arrival by general 6555 - X 23 arrived
with no passengers and loaded past
carrying capacity with instances of
scp-2401 have since been unsuccessful an
unmanned drone has since been deployed
to to investigate SCP 1124 addendum B
research drone X 23 e was able to gain
access to the research bay at aleena
unidentified variations of SCP 1124 were
discovered before comm loss with the
drone reference SCP 1124 video
transcript see and this is SCP 1124
video transcript see classification
number 1124 1 description small each
exactly one point zero two six eight
kilograms and generally inactive
metallic in appearance as a distinct
cone-shaped mantle and is perfectly
bilaterally symmetrical speculated to
activate when exposed to biological
matter each signature none
classification number 1124 - description
anatomically similar to common spiders
differs in appearance from spiders in
that the body segments are fused into
four tag Motta and joined by for
cylindrical peda cells has one interior
antenna ignores research drone x-23 II
heat signature
none classification number eleven twenty
four five description hominid appearance
appears in multiple places in different
frames after following the drone for
some time a large flare damaged thermal
sensors heat signature for micrometers
classification number eleven twenty four
eighty eight description we can conclude
the material composing the progeny of
eleven twenty four is vincible in other
frames the material is shown to have
regenerated heat signature
non-applicable classification number
eleven 2489 description heat signature
eight micrometers classification number
eleven 24/7 description entity ignored
research drone allowing for a close
inspection has a tail equal in length to
its body two sets of serrated teeth each
approximately ten centimeters in length
observed destroying walls in theta and
consuming them the consumption seems to
be aided by elongated nostrils near its
interior heat signature five point four
five micrometers classification number
11246 description heat signature data in
validated classification number eleven
twenty four twenty four description
fluctuated and appearance wildly
although this may be due to damaged
thermal sensors subject first appears
reptilian in appearance heat signature 2
micrometers classification number eleven
twenty four twenty three description
caused considerable damage to x 23 e
sampling actuators completely dissolved
heat signature data invalidated
classification number 1124 description
after some observation these subjects
appearance altered to vanity and
gestured as if to suggest that drone do
so researchers remotely operating the
drone attempt to communicate with the
entity as a result of this verbal
stimulus the entity charges toward the
drone and finally communication with
x-23 II ceases no further data could be
obtained each signature data invalidated
compilers note addendum D instances of a
sepia Levin 24s progeny that expressed
low heat signature very slightly in
appearance but share some
characteristics including metallic
angular features and segmented limbs
entities with higher heat signatures
appear less angular and are not
segmented some bodily features are
similar to animals that were previously
housed on site although these influences
seemed to be primarily reptilian
temperatures on range from minus 208 to
minus 223 degrees Celsius and surface
gravity is roughly 44 point 88 life
support systems at aleena are not
functional gravity stabilization
generators inside aleena are also non
functioning the atmosphere would corrode
most earth metals these entities do not
require air and are composed of
currently unclassified organic material
and metals testing is requested on earth
housed samples to confirm whether
environmental factors affect the
abilities of SCP 1124 as testing on
active samples at a ena is limited due
to a fer mentioned conditions at aleena
and the limitations of the research
drones the following paragraph was
stricken from the document
video-recording 1124 see area researcher
enters area 1124 see carrying container
with one instance of a sepia leaven 24
loses balance a tear is shown on closer
inspection near the researchers like a
negligible amount of blood is spilled on
the casing the casing begins to move
around and slide along the floor places
two hands on the casing effectively
stopping it from moving a small hole
appears on the casing surface researcher
places one hand over the hole and
quickly recoils in pain a figure
matching typical appearance of SCP 1124
- one emerges from the hole slightly
pausing for roughly three seconds
remains still and continues looking at
SCP 1124 SCP 1124 retreats into the hole
produces emergency film from a storage
closet near unit 11 24 C and leans over
the box to begin applying it to the
casing as CP 1124 shoots out of its
casing into the mouth he appears to
panic runs into cell 1124 C and begins
punching a button linking to the
failsafe doors - unit 1124 C lock and
the chamber begins filling with true
flick acid and mist Ted appears to
inflate slightly collapses skull appears
through cracks in the skin on the head
blood beginning to drain from cranial
orifices at this point filming is
obscured by acid all but completely
filling the tank the sound of a metallic
screeching can be heard followed by a
dull thud and a sound similar to a
balloon popping
all right I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to pierce M Hamlin Muslim
Mookie slump God dr. day John Porter
captain Gorge fluffy sky key mana moon a
my archive curator Nick
Tai verbal Cody tench cheese whip
I'm Depp's McGee thank you all so much
for your support I really appreciate it
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos on some
other cool stuff as well as at
patreon.com forward slash the vulcan
thank you
[Music]
you